[Musique]
joël 17 ans apprenti à la manufacture
jacky fonteneau apprentis 19 ans
rappelle jean-michel 14,1 fait l'école
quels sont vos loisirs quoi les occuper
vous le samedi après midi avec des
camarades dans les cafés ou baby food
roche sur yon powell dans les cafés tout
ça on les bat le soir j'ai au cinéma et
la musique julie je m'appelle jean
jacques du 18 ans parents sont bourgeois
j'aime beaucoup de cinéma je fais une
collection de porte-clés je serais
content pour les maisons jones ne
m'intéresse pas parce que garnements
pour ça
je m'appelle martin
quelle saison
je regrette pas non plus une maison de
jeunes particulièrement le fonds
commercial les portes clair les poupées
de collection à ses états membres
justement pas tout
j'ai 17 ans et demi je suis étudiant
dans un lycée technique
et
je dis quoi fâcher pour quoi faire qui
avec des copains cinémale dimanche aussi
quand je fais du sport dans mon lycée il
a alors mon violon dingue c'est le sport
le sport
fréquentez pas les maisons
quelquefois on soit uni entre jeunes
dans une maison non je fréquente fois
que je l'aï vu 22 ans étudiant en
quatrième année de droit
alors j'aime beaucoup la chasse et la
pêche alors à poitiers que le question
de loisirs je crois que c'est un peu il
n'y a pas grand chose à part de trois
boîtes de nuit arrive grand violon
dingue c'est par une bien la peinture
monique
peine deux ans j'aime beaucoup la danse
la natation
sylvie 18 ans je suis étudiante en droit
j'aime beaucoup la lecture de natation à
danse entièrement
sport il faut regarder par exemple
à bien y en ait
si la lecture
le cinéma
tu manques que le cinéma
alors 18 ans je suis étudiant enfin
étudiants ou lycéens
je fais partie d'un groupe de jeunes ont
fasciné club photo club
est-ce qu'ils occupent aujourd hui si la
photo moi je fais de la photo
deux trois fois par semaine
on a du ciné club on a toujours la pièce
de théâtre alors mon prénom c'est
francis je suis étudiant en droit chez
la fac de droit
vous allez me demander à quoi je quitte
mes loisirs évidemment rabat poitiers
savez ya pas tellement tellement de
loisirs alors le dimanche les contrastes
d'aller au cinéma soit d'aller au bal
bien encore les ca des balles vous savez
alors plupart du temps on est là se
balader dans les rues à se trimbaler
maison c'est un salut oui quelquefois
quand on voit qu'un programme nous le
prêter ou au cinéma on va maison john
avec des copains on se réunit mais sans
plus quant au non moi ce que cherche
cherche à faire noblesse mais votre âge
battant et va pas non abbas avait pas
besoin de vous le dire lui pas me le
dire
quels sont vos occupations un peu de
tout quoi et je fais un peu de guitare
quoi
vous travaillez pas ça je pense que
c'est voulu dire non plus vous ne l'avez
pas non plus mais quels sont vos loisirs
préférés en dehors de la musique
pourquoi j'aime bien j'aime bien prendre
mais quoi cinéma pas question de cinéma
télévision un peu baby-foot les
appareils électriques avec à peine un
loyer fixe au box
pieper à une moto non à vélomoteur non
plus
[Musique]